böhm
[Música]
conocido por su sigla tease mo y por su
reputación de don juan le dio vida al
agente james bond un rol que lo
catapultó al súper estrellato
pero los orígenes de song connery se
alejan y por mucho del glamour
hollywoodense ha nacido en edimburgo en
1939 hijo de un padre camionero y una
madre que trabajaba en tareas de
limpieza
connor y tuvo una larga serie de empleos
a lo largo de su juventud incluyendo una
temporada en la marina y un tiempo como
repartidor de leche su hobby de
levantamiento de pesas lo llevó a
obtener un lugar en la competencia de
mister universo en 1953
[Música]
jirones
con él y fue el primer actor en llevar a
la gente de ian fleming a la pantalla
grande protagonizando 6 películas de
james bond su imponente estatura de 187
y sus modales suaves lo hicieron
interpretar el rol con naturalidad era
tan creíble enfrentando a villanos como
seduciendo a mujeres pero con el tiempo
connery enfrentó acusaciones de
misoginia dentro y fuera del escenario
en una entrevista con playboy en 1973
dijo que no veía nada malo en pegarle a
las mujeres era una persona que no se
guardaba sus opiniones apoyaba
vehementemente la independencia escocesa
y apoyó el fallido referendo del 2014
continuó actuando hasta sus años dorados
ganando un oscar en 1988 por los
intocables cuando tenía casi 60 años
connor y fue nombrado como el hombre más
sexy del mundo por la revista people
ese mismo año protagonizó la película la
roca con catherine zeta-jones pero
siempre será recordado como el agente
secreto de su majestad
[Música]